ultimately that's what we do in
television is we take complex ideas and
we take people the audience and our
journey and help them understand things
whether it be
in drama or
non-scripted this is one of those
horrible questions but it's and i'll go
to your first clear
it's it's about that this aspect of what
is an idea and if you're a commissioner
what's the difference between a concept
and a fully fledged tv idea
well i think i think obviously lots of
different genres have different
approaches to this but i think
fundamentally the difference between an
a concept and an idea is the how to make
it how to make it happen so um
um
if you take um i'm a celebrity as an
example you know like um
we we've got we've got some celebs in
the jungle and they're going to compete
to get out that doesn't tell you
anything about what the idea is that
could go a million different ways so i
think a fully fledged idea would contain
the bush tucker trials the
the voting the
elements that make it particular that
particularly that program would you also
at that stage would you be
looking for kind of examples of the
casting that you would have in it you
know to give a sense of that idea
i think that depends um on i think i
think examples are really good
i was thinking about that actually about
whether to
when when is it right to attach someday
to a project and i think it really
depends what stage you are with your
conversations with a channel because
um what you don't want to do is become
so
embroiled in you know
in attaching the wrong person
um so that your idea
unless unless that idea is so much that
person in which case that's fair enough
but if you're attaching somebody to an
idea i wouldn't do that without
consultation with the channel really i
would just put in an idea some ideas
that you think would float their boats
and steph in the world of drama i i'd
imagine this is even more crucial
because um is that when does an idea
become a
concept yeah well i mean a concept in
drama is quite often just the seeds the
very beginning so
someone might be talking about a
territory they're interested in
exploring or
a character they want to develop a show
around
but when it comes to what's the idea
we've thought about kind of emotional
arcs and the narrative journey what what
journeys we're taking specific
characters on what we want the audience
to feel who the audience is
so it's really just going into the
nitty-gritty whereas the concept is just
the very beginnings of the territory
that we want to talk about
and and i think
it it's very
easy to have a concept and think that
that's the idea and that's you ready to
go but actually
most of the time what we're dealing with
when we're talking about pitching and
getting back to people is we need to
have a really clear idea of what it is
that you want to do in order to give you
a clear answer
and quite often just going on a concept
is it's not really enough in the last
five six years it does feel as though
there's been a bit of a revolution in
how we we place our ideas it used to be
there was it would be a two-page
treatment that'd been microsoft word
it'd have a nice font and three pictures
at the top and a picture of your main
talent and now we actually have you know
a powerpoint presentations which you
know we get you know development teams
usually employ really good people people
with good graphic design skills on them
now and i tell
especially in the netflix world it gives
you an idea of the kind of the ambition
the look you know the visuals of it so
steph in the world of
drama treatments and drama treatments
are quite they're quite complicated
beasts as well because
i presume story comes first yeah how
much are the visuals now in a part of
that
well what's really interesting is i
think in drama
we are just much more about the purity
of the idea so
whilst
sometimes these documents are brilliant
at building tone which is so important
and giving us an idea of the world we're
going to be in
i think really
if
if i was being honest what what's much
more likely to kind of get through is
just the words on the page
for us really the idea needs to speak
for itself and all the other elements
can come later we can talk about the
look and the feel and the cast
further down the line but to get onto
the development sleeping slate initially
we're really just
looking for the idea and the voice
so it really comes down to the writing
so
if you're an established writer who's
had their own shows on and and we know
who you are we know what you can deliver
that's maybe
you know just a treatment just a pitch
could even air towards more of that
contact area we were in earlier but if
you're a new writer or you're coming to
us with a newer
talent
we would want a kind of more fleshed out
document you need to convince us more
basically
and also what i would say is really
crucial at that point is a sample script
so
as you can have a brilliant idea but we
need to know that you can write that you
can that you have a sense of voice
that's going to bring an audience that
you can build characters and and those
are characters we can engage with across
the script
so
for drama it's probably you know it's
just the pure simple writing that really
takes precedence at this point going
back to your um development days
what was the process you would involve
yourself in and you would um take on in
order to take something from concept to
what was kind of more commission already
yeah i think it's just really important
to think about your audience
so who
who you want to speak to and what it is
you're trying to say and the the age-old
question why now like
why is it you're telling this story now
what truth does it speak about the world
we're living in now
and
what what's it got to say and what's it
going to get people thinking and talking
about
and i think also obviously character is
a huge one you need to really
interrogate your characters and you know
similarly similar to what claire was
saying drama kind of the
anyone who's trained in drama will know
there's sort of 10 questions you ask
about your characters what they want and
what they need and all these things and
and to go away and do that with all your
characters is really important so that
you really understand who these people
are and
when you're talking about their
motivations and their turning points
everything feels very authentic to that
character
and i think
from a commissioner's perspective as
well when you're reading a treatment or
a pitch character authenticity is so
important you can really tell if people
have gone away and done that work
or if they've
just if they're telling you a story that
they think suits a channel suits
a specific kind of genre
but it doesn't necessarily feel truthful
i think it always comes back to making
sure your idea is really truthful
really authentic to the writer and to
the audience that you're trying to
engage with
so see we've got our concept and then
we want to turn it into a fully formed
idea and i bore everybody by saying the
phrase no idea is born beautiful and
what do you think
before we're going to you going to take
it on
to the pitch meeting
what do you need to do to an idea clear
to actually
form it into i suppose a
a you know a form that is ready to be
viewed by a commissioner
i heard it was a writing event but i
heard julian fellow speak many many
years ago about how he never asks his
friends and family what they think of an
idea he asks them what they don't
understand
and you get so much because basically if
you ask your friends and family what you
think of an idea oh it's great or oh i
don't know you know it's very difficult
for them to give a
an answer to that whereas if you ask
somebody what they don't understand that
is much easier for them to to express
and
and i'm saying that because i think that
asking the questions of the idea whether
you you ask as many questions as you can
to um get clarity of it but then also
before you're pitching ask people that
haven't ever heard it before and what
didn't you understand and come up with
the answers for as many things that will
make it as clear and understandable as
humanly possible because ultimately
that's what we do in television is we
take complex ideas and we take people
the audience and our journey and help
them understand things whether it be
in drama or
non-scripted before we go into the world
of the kind of the physical pitching i
thought it may be helpful to actually
understand you know what the
commissioner you know before you open
the door and you go into the well if you
ever get into an office again to go and
actually face a commissioner
what is their existence like but clear
what is the kind of environment that a
commissioner exists in the pressures
there under the kind of the ideas the
flood of ideas that they can up the
torrent that they face each week i think
the reality is that their commissioners
are sitting there waiting for a great
idea i mean there's i can't imagine any
commissioner not wanting a great idea to
walk into into the room but the reality
is
is the ideas are a bit like a curved jaw
curve a bell curved jar there are very
very few terrible ideas and there are
very very few brilliant ideas and
there's a myriad
of you know all right ideas and they're
much more difficult to decide between
aren't they the the reality is is
you know oh those apples are those pears
well you know i get a bit of fitting
nonetheless whereas the the really
brilliant ideas they totally stand out
and um
so i think that funnily enough i think
that often people think commissioners
don't want good ideas and they can't see
it coming and all that um but
just be odd i've never met a
commissioner and i certainly every
picture i listen to is desperate for it
to be something new and interesting that
we hadn't seen before and it happened i
was very very lucky it happened to me
two or three times
you know and i
that that was an amazing experience when
i started commissioning the guy that
brought me in paul jackson amazing man
he told me that the job was selection
and quality control
so and that i think that's a really
clear way of explaining what
commissioning is so you're not only
selecting ideas and championing them
through the system of the channel that
you're working on which means that you
go to you know whatever questions the
commissioners ask their bosses and other
people around them and commercial teams
and business people and marketing people
are going to be asking them all
questions about this idea too
but you're also
you know quality controlling it through
so at any one time when i when i was at
itv i would probably have about i don't
know
8 to 15
things that were in
were in production that i was being at
you know asked to sign off on things but
whether it be an editor or go to a
studio or sign off and cast or whatever
plus the the day-to-day of finding new
ideas how important is it
for people to know who they're pitching
to
actually clear could you could you tell
us some of the kind of the mistakes that
you've seen happen because people you
know go and not know in the channel the
commissioner or
and as that astonishes me that there's
actually quite a lot of people who work
in telly who don't don't watch it that's
really difficult because there's all
sorts of mistakes you can make and i
think it's not about what mistakes you
make it's how you
act in the in the light of those
mistakes
um so you know um
particularly in today's world i don't
think anyone when i started
commissioning i would have expected
everybody to know what was on
the channels that i was commissioning i
just don't believe that's um
completely possible nowadays i think
that that you might make mistakes
because there is so much television on
that it's really difficult to know so i
think uh in that context it's all about
how you
recover from a mistake like that and um
um you know maybe ask if there's a way
that it would work on the channel that
you're on or listening to what they're
saying because actually the
commissioners have
they've got a different prism that
they're looking at the world the the
industry through they're looking at it
through their channel and you're wanting
to make a program for their channel
therefore they've got lots of
um
[Music]
data
and information and insights that that
you could never have so although it's
good to know what they've commissioned
last and what sort of things they like
and
uh and all those things um actually i
think it was a first meeting
um it's as is wise to
listen and say you know i've got these
ideas i'd be really interested to know
what you think of them they might not be
right for you at the moment but that
would be as useful
as knowing
what's wrong about them because at the
end of the day a a good working
relationship with a commissioner is a
collaboration
yeah i was just gonna say it's very much
about communication isn't it you want to
be having conversations often and
when we were talking about concepts
earlier whilst you maybe wouldn't pitch
them formally
it's great to just have chats informally
as often as possible so that you can be
seeing as a producer a writer
this is something i'm thinking about
exploring and then we can say quite
early on well actually we've got x y and
z in that area
or that's not really somewhere that
we're interested in going at the moment
so it's just about having conversations
and
and listening to to what's out there and
what you know is coming up and yeah you
absolutely can't be watching everything
that's on tv but i suppose knowing the
audience that you're
targeting and what channel
they fit in with making sure that you're
pitching the idea to the right person
and
feels important
you